- Well, well, well, well.
- Hi.
- Well wait, I was-
- How are you?
- I'm great, but you're doing well!
- I am.
- So, congratulations.
We need to start with a big congrats,
I don't know if everybody knows,
but last month you said that you'd
been undergoing cancer
treatment for a year,
which I didn't know about,
so I don't know then
if many people knew about-
- 'Cause you're not supposed to know
about it.
- Yeah, I was like, I don't
think many people knew about-
- I kept it quiet.
- You did!
- Yes.
- And you got the news that
you're now cancer-free, right?
- I am.
(audience cheering)
Yeah.
Thank you.
- That's a hard thing to keep quiet!
- I...
Listen-
- [Kelly] Just physically,
while you're working.
- Yeah, it is.
It was hard.
The thing was, I didn't
wanna say anything.
I don't want pity, and
I don't have a publicist
that you release it and everybody says,
"Oh my God, Kelly."
I didn't want that.
- Yeah.
- That happens.
- I just wanted to keep it quiet.
My family knew.
And then, as you can tell,
I'm a little self-conscious
about my appearance, but
that's from the treatments.
And people were saying,
what's wrong with me?
What's wrong with me?
And so finally, I thank Fox
for allowing me the time to say
- Yeah.
- in November I was diagnosed
with bladder cancer.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And I went on this treatment at Baylor,
I didn't mean Baylor, Yale Medical Center
up in New Haven,
Connecticut for six weeks.
Then I came back and was diagnosed
weeks later, cancer-free.
But I still do follow up treatments
which I still have to go back up for that.
- Which are hard on your body.
- You have no idea.
I had no idea!
- Yeah.
- It's bladder cancer,
and then in March,
I'm getting ready to go to
Hawaii, and I'm all excited
I get a vacation after,
well, over two years.
And I was having trouble with my neck,
and I go in, my wife says,
"We need to get that checked."
And then they found a
tumor here. (chuckles)
So that's Merkel cell cancer.
- Oh my God.
- It's a form of skin cancer.
It's relatively rare.
Had it not been for this, then
we wouldn't have found that.
- Yeah, they didn't catch it.
- So they cut all that out,
and now my face is a
little, I'm self-conscious.
My wife says, "You look fine."
But-
- Yeah, I gotta be honest
with you, it's just-
- But my-
- If I had...
- Yeah, I didn't know.
- But you know what Kelly?
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- It's like,
I'm so self-conscious of my face.
One good thing about
it, though, I don't have
to shave, cause I have no hair
over here.
(audience and Kelly laugh)
So it's been a long battle.
And then I went back to MD Anderson
and got cancer-free here.
- Jeez,
- So,
what a blessing though.
- as we do this interview-
- Yeah.
(audience applauding)
- But...
It's like, "One cancer, wow!"
Two?
- Two, yeah.
- Two is
a little bit overwhelming.
- When it rains, it pours.
- Yeah.
- But I've always had a
great attitude about it.
Never thought that it was,
I never, I don't know why.
Maybe it's my faith.
- Well, do you-
- My faith has kept me, I never said,
"Well if I die, I'm going to
a good place, no big deal.
And if I live, it's a great deal."
One of these days, I'm
gonna be able to talk
about the treatments,
'cause I'm gonna tell
you something right now.
- Yeah.
- (clears throat) Funny.
(Kelly and Terry laugh)
- You're like,
you're not there yet.
- Funny!
- Yeah.
But the stuff that happens,
it's amazing.
(Terry laughs)
Wait, so all this is happening
and you also moved houses, right?
- I did, we have lived in
Thackerville, Oklahoma.
We're horse ranchers.
We (chuckles) raise quarter
horses halter, and we breed
and we train halter.
- Yeah.
- We stand 12 stallions.
Now, 11, I sold one today.
- Congratulations.
- Thank you very much.
- That's a big sell, yeah.
- That's a big thing.
(audience cheers)
- Yeah, yeah.
- (chuckles) And I felt
like after the cancer,
Tammy, my wife, we decided,
"Hey, let's downsize."
- Yeah.
- We moved to a little town
called Saint Jo, Texas.
You know where that is?
- I don't know
where that is.
- Okay.
- But Thackerville is not big.
- There's 70-
No, Thackerville's not big
at all.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Thackerville, I'm behind WinStar Casino.
- I know where Thackerville is.
- Yes.
- My best friend
from childhood is from Thackerville.
- Ah.
- Her family. (laughs)
- Are you serious?
- Yes, that's why when you said that
- Got all her teeth?
- I was like, "Wait, what?"
Yes, yes.
(audience laughs)
She made it out.
Yeah, she did.
(Terry laughs)
She got all her teeth.
- Yeah.
- But we're right
behind WinStar Casino,
- WinStar, yeah,
yeah.
- okay?
And so we moved, backed up the highway
to Highway 82 outta Gainesville.
- Yeah.
- 16 miles due west, you're in Saint Jo.
And listen, folks, I
haven't been pulled over
for speeding or doing
anything wrong in 40 years.
My first...
(audience applauding)
Yeah.
- I feel like I should-
- My first, hey, hey listen!
My first... (chuckles)
My first week in Saint Jo, which has one-
- Cop. (laughs)
- Red light.
One cop, yeah.
- One cop. (laughs)
- I get pulled over, and I said,
(whispers) "What'd I do wrong?"
He said, "Well, yous doing 55 in a 30."
(audience laughs)
- They do frown on that.
- Where-
Yeah, well, I said, "Yeah.
And I, oh, 30.
30 what?"
He said, "That's a school system,
school thing back 'ere.
And I went, I didn't...
I basically said, "You gotta be kidding."
- Yeah, 'cause you didn't
realize it was even there.
- And he goes, (clears throat)
- Yeah.
- "I'm gonna let you off."
Well, it took 45 minutes
before he come back.
'cause he gotta run your
tags and everything.
He comes back and said,
"I'm gonna let you off this time.
We got you in the system."
(everyone laughs)
What does that mean? (laughs)
- Okay.
- "We've got you in the system,
boy."
- First of all,
I love that you were like,
"He took 45 minutes."
(Terry laughs)
Meanwhile he's back there going,
"You will never believe
who I just pulled over."
(Terry and the audience laugh)
'cause you don't pull
over anybody like that
in Saint Jo. (laughs)
- Well, my, oh no.
My wife is from Rogers, Missouri.
Rogers...
Yes, Rogers.
Rogersville.
- Right out of Branson.
- I don't know.
Oh, okay.
- Rogersville.
- I know that one.
- Rogers...
She's back here.
God, is it Rogers?
Rogersville?
- I'm mad for her
right now. (laughs)
- Okay.
- Anyway, he goes back to her car.
I don't play the celebrity routine.
I don't do that well.
- Yeah.
- I will never do it.
I'm just Terry Bradshaw.
I may be this, but I'm really this.
She says-
- That's how I feel. (laughs)
- She goes, "Honey, tell him who you are."
"I'm not gonna tell
this guy who I am."
- "Who I am." (chuckles)
First of all, I'm in Texas.
(audience laugh)
This is cowboy country.
(Kelly laughs)
Who beat 'em in the Super Bowls?
The Steelers.
- Yeah.
- Who was the quarterback?
Me!
(audience laughs)
This is not good!
- Remind them of that.
Yeah, would you believe it?
- No!
I couldn't!
(Kelly laughs)
I'm trying to take all my Steelers stuff
out of my car and stuff it!
- Yeah. (laughs)
- It's not good.
- Oh my God, I love it.
(Terry laughs)
We do come out of the
womb loving the cowboys.
Oh, wait, in this new house,
(audience cheering)
you got another parrot?
- It's not a parrot, it's a Macaw.
(audience laugh)
- Which I totally know
the difference.
- Is that a parrot?
It's a parrot?
- Is this like-
- This lady's goin', "Yep, it's a parrot."
It's a big ass parrot!
(Kelly and the audience)
- Hey, look.
I made the lady in makeup...
(audience exclaim)
- Wait, is this the parrot?
- What happened?
- Oh, here he goes!
Oh, wow!
- Oh, yeah, that's Dude.
- That's Dude?
- That's Dude.
Yeah, he's, boy, he's a biting son.
- Look.
- You-
- I made 'em cover my-
- Oh my gosh!
- Oh, he...
Yeah.
The Dude, I named him after Jeff Bridges
in The Big Lebowski.
- Dude, Big Lebowski. (laughs)
- Dude!
I'm the dude!
Okay.
(audience applauds)
So I named this Macaw,
I always wanted one.
And my kids bought this for my birthday.
And so I said, "I'm
gonna name him The Dude."
I thought that was so cool.
(audience laugh)
So, it's The Dude.
So we go off, come back,
we go pick up The Dude.
And they went, "Mr.
Bradshaw, we sexed The Dude,
and it's a female."
- Oh.
(audience laugh)
- But he knows his name as The Dude.
So it's The Dude, it's a female...
The Dude, and so-
- Yep.
- If I get to come back on the show,
I'll bring you a picture of Peanut.
- The Dude, is that, wait-
- That's the second one.
- The second one,
and is this a boy or a girl?
- And he's a
boy.
- So it kind of goes-
- The Dude-
- Yeah.
- The Dude is a female,
and Peanut's a male.
And right now, The Dude
can't stand Peanut.
- Oh.
- But I think
when nature takes his course,
(Kelly laughs)
they'll be getting along just fine.
(audience and Kelly laughing)
Just fine.
(audience applauds)
(Terry laughs)
- So, wait.
I didn't know, so Macaw,
if you get another one,
name it McGraw, after Tim.
'cause come on.
- Tim McGraw?
Yeah, McGraw.
- Well, I wanna tell you,
- Come on.
- I got another one.
- You do?
- I got an African Gray.
They are some talking Jessies.
Oh, oh, I saw it out of the nest.
They just took it out of the nest.
Kelly, I'm telling you,
(gasp) I just melted and, oh.
And the guy knows me.
He's sucker, he's sticking it to me.
I paid 10 grand for that bird.
(Kelly and audience laugh)
And he goes, "Well, I
paid 10 grand for Peanut."
- Yeah. (laughs)
- Peanut probably cost $500
anywhere else.
- Yeah.
- I got 10 grand out of me.
- Yeah (laughs)
But I saw this bird, I went,
(gasps) "I gotta have that bird."
And he says, "I'm saving him for you.
He's special."
Yeah, I don't know what do you call,
I bought him, but I don't
know what I paid for him.
I have no idea.
So, I come home-
- Sometimes, you just
don't look. (laughs)
- Yeah.
So we come home, my wife's
thinking, Tammy, she goes,
"I got a name for the African Gray."
- Okay.
- I said, "Well, we got
Peanut. We got The Dude.
Whatchu got?"
She said, "Steve."
- Steve?
(Terry laughs)
- Steve!
(everyone laughs)
Steve!
- What?
- You can't name a bird Steve!
- Yeah, you can.
Why?
- So-
- Why it's Steve?
- Yeah,
that dumb ass bird's name is Steve!
(everyone laughs)
- Why?
Did she have a reason?
- I have no...
My wife is extremely intelligent.
and I just think
(Kelly laughs)
when people walk in the
house and Peanut's hollering,
and The Dude's hollering,
it would be nice to have
someone named Steve.
- Steve, yeah.
(audience laugh)
- So the bird's name is
Steve.
- Steve.
I actually...
If I get to come on again,
- Yeah. (laughs)
- I'll bring Steve.
I'll bring Steve.
- It okay.
- Yeah,
he's-
- And if you have another one,
McGraw.
- I'm not...
- McGraw! Macaw!
- Well, when The Dude-
- Tim Macaw.
(chuckles) You like Tim McGraw?
- I just like the name. (laughs)
I like him too.
- Macaw, McGraw.
When The Dude and Peanut get
together and have babies.
- Tim Macaw, yeah.
- Tim Macaw, is that funny?
(Kelly and the audience laugh)
- Very cute.
I'm getting it in there.
- Just now, yeah,
you're-
- Getting it in there.
- You are so sharp.
(Kelly laughs)
You are so sharp.
By the end of this,
you're gonna have a damn bird
named Tim Macaw. (laughs)
- Yeah.
(audience laughs)
Oh, for sure!
- Wait, I hear this.
So you're a singer as well,
and I don't think I knew this about you.
- Yeah, I'm pretty good.
- I know.
I googled you, by the way.
(Terry laughs)
- These people are going,
- No-
"All right."
- No. (laughs)
(indistinct)
- No, I googled.
You have full on, full voice vibrato.
Like every, I literally googled you.
- Kelly.
- Because they told me this
and I didn't know this.
- Kelly.
- I grew up on gospel.
- Okay.
- I always wanted to be a singer,
and God made me a football player.
And now I turned 74,
and I started singing.
I opened up in Vegas seven
years ago at the Mirage.
- What?
How did I miss this?
- Yeah, you're not
the only one that can knock
it out of the park, okay?
(Kelly and the audience laugh)
- Well, wait.
- So I-
- So wait.
- Yeah.
When I was Googling,
- Right.
- I saw you at the Opry.
You were at the Opry?
- I did the Opry
with The Isaacs and my daughter.
- That's incredible!
- And then I do the Clay
Cooper Theatre in Branson.
Did 20 shows there.
- Right, yeah.
- Yeah.
- Wow!
Love Branson.
- Me too, yeah.
- Love Branson.
- We all toured through
there, right?
- Well, yeah, I mean, listen.
I've been listening to your music.
When it comes to singing,
when it comes to a set of pipes.
Girl. (blows lips)
- You are very nice.
(audience applaud)
- You are amazing.
- But you get it, though.
You love it.
- Yeah.
- You love it.
- Right.
- It makes you feel good.
- Yeah, I love singing.
- Yeah, I didn't know that about you.
- I just love it
- I thought that was so cool.
- Yeah.
(audience cheer)
- So,
do you still get starstruck
at this point in your life?
I still get giddy.
Like when I see people, I'm just like,
"Oh, man!"
- Yeah.
- I'm kind of on weird people
- But you're a host.
You gotta kinda be cool.
You're in Hollywood.
- I'm not.
- You're Hollywood out here.
- That's why when you said
people think I'm here.
Yeah, I'm not.
- No, you're good.
See, here's the thing about you.
The great thing about a host,
I did Jay Luno for 54
times on the Tonight Show,
and he and I were just. (claps)
- He's the nicest human ever.
- Just like that.
And the thing is, a host, like yourself,
is someone that makes
the guest comfortable.
- Yeah.
- Where they can relax
and be themselves.
(audience applauds)
- Yeah.
- And I have always, for years,
now they'll still laugh at this, I hope,
thought that the best looking dude,
and I'm very strong heterosexual, but the-
- I love the preface. (laughs)
- Yes.
(audience laugh)
He is my...
What do you call that?
Ganger?
- [Alex] Doppelganger.
- Doppelganger.
- Who said that?
- That was Alex.
- Oh, yeah.
- Yeah?
- Yeah.
Doppelganger.
- My doppelganger.
- Who?
- Brad Pitt!
- [Kelly] Brad.
(audience cheers)
You met Brad Pitt?
- I don't-
- Have you met-
- No.
- No?
- I've never met-
- Oh, I'm telling you.
- I never met Brad Pitt
- I'm afraid.
I'm afraid.
And I always tell everybody,
"Oh, you know, I get people
say I look like Brad Pitt."
I've used Brad Pitt's name forever.
I'm sure he's heard about it.
And the-
- Well, can we...
I just wanna see a side
by side real quick,
cuz I just need a recap.
- Oh, it's not gonna be good.
- I just need a recap.
- Oh.
- Yeah.
There we go.
(audience cheer)
There we go!
I see it.
Look at the black leather.
Yeah, I'm definitely-
- Yeah.
- I would remember if I'd met him.
- I gotta admit that's not a good look.
(Kelly chuckles)
(audience laugh)
- It's a great look
for both of you
- As my wife says, I'm stud.
(Kelly laughs)
(audience cheers)
- I love that.
- Yeah, I'm stud.
- Oh, that's...
After how many years now?
- We've been together 22 years.
- Do you like how I was
trying to catch ya? (laughs)
I was trying to catch ya.
How many years now?
- No, no.
You weren't gonna catch me.
I love it, I love it.
- No,
you're not gonna catch me.
I had 22 years.
- That's awesome.
- 23, yeah.
Met her at the X-ray machine
at the hospital.
(Kelly and the audience laugh)
What?
What are you laughing for?
- What?
- That's where you met?
- I brought a guy in
with a broke ankle.
(Kelly laughs)
And it was a changer for me.
And down comes this...
I'm talking knocked down,
dead gorgeous blonde
with a hair pulled up. (blows lips)
(Kelly and the audience laugh)
And I'm like,
"Oh my God, that woman is gorgeous!"
And I'm sitting here-
- So you hit on her
by an X-ray machine. (laughs)
- So I'm standing next to her.
She is a head of X-rays,
whatever that means.
Radiologist.
(audience laugh)
And so they're running
it, and she's running it.
And I come to find out later
when she found out I was down there.
- Oh.
- She said,
"Outta the way, girls!"
- Yeah. (laughs)
- "He's mine!"
- I love that.
(audience cheer)
- Yeah.
And later, I found out she said,
"I always get what I want."
- Oh my God! (laughs)
(Terry screams)
- I like her.
- So, she's standing there,
and I'm-
- She does belong in Texas.
- I'm checking her out, man.
I'm going, "Wow!
What a fine looking woman!"
(Kelly laughs)
So I didn't have the, I wasn't gonna say,
"Excuse me, Tammy.
I'm Terry Bradshaw, and I
would like to take you to..."
I think you go to lunch, don't you?
Never go to dinner on the first date,
cuz if you go to dinner,
you gotta stay for the whole thing.
If you go for lunch, you can always leave.
Is that how that works?
- I never heard that rule.
So I just suffered
- Okay, that's a rule.
- through some dinners.
Yeah.
- Follow it.
Follow it.
- Okay. (laughs)
- And so, I said, "Hey (indistinct)"
And I wouldn't have never said that,
because she could very easily
said she didn't have a ring on.
Cause I dang sure X-ray'd
her finger on that.
(Kelly and the audience laugh)
No ring on.
But she could have been
married, and she wasn't.
And I didn't ask her because
she could have, (exhales)
"No, I don't date guys like you."
She could have said that.
- Yeah.
- And I would've just
been devastated.
So, I did what most
secure 60 year old men do,
50 year old men.
I went to a doctor and I said,
"Buddy there's a hot blonde named Tammy
in the X-ray place."
He goes, "Oh, you're talking
about Tammy Luttrull."
I say, "Is that her name?"
He said, "Yeah, yeah, everybody wants,
everybody wants some of that."
(Kelly laughs)
Well...
(audience applauds)
Hey, that's what they said.
- Yes, Tammy!
- All right?
That's what...
(Kelly laughs)
- Tammy was killing that! (laughs)
- Well, yeah, the old Tammy.
Yeah.
And then he said, "Yeah."
I said, "I'd like to ask her out.
Could you find out if
she'd go out with me?"
- (laughs) Oh my God.
That's what I did.
What am I supposed to do?
- That's so cute!
- Oh, it's cute.
- That's like what you'd
do in grade school.
I love that! (laughs)
(audience love)
You know, you find out from a friend.
- Okay.
- You know?
That's sweet!
- Have you ever
been sweet?
- I like that.
Have you ever been sweet
on someone and-
- Yeah.
- And said, "No matter how old you are."
And said, (gasps) "Oh I'd
love that guy to ask me out."
So, did you go up to him and say,
"Will you ask me out?"
- No, I have asked-
- No.
- No, I have literally gone
up to a person's house,
knocked the door, asked them out.
- Stop it!
And no, it was a guy that I liked
and got...
(audience applauds)
No.
And got turned down.
- That's my point!
- I don't wanna
- I know!
- get turned down.
But I got turned down,
I cried and I got over.
- There you go!
That stress.
- Yeah.
Yeah!
- That's bad!
- No, it's just you're never
gonna know unless you ask.
And the odds are in your favor depending
on how many. (laughs)